all right tonight I will be with the
stars of Star Trek beyond for the
premiere in San Diego I will be your
official red carpet host meanwhile our
Carly Steele sat down with the cast in
she boldly went where few journalists
have ever gone she opened up their high
school yearbooks I have the Star Trek
year buck with some high school photos
which you can guess who they are
Oh No Michelle Obama Alyssa get was
taken in the future Wow we're gonna talk
to him about that there's like a
microphone oh my gosh good stuff you
know we aim your ladies didn't like me
that much
will you go with me to prom absolutely
John who's this
I have no idea come on that's me hey is
that that's me is that really you
tonight now I see it holy cow Wow crazy
man
is it Chris Pine no oh my god yeah
even Captain Kirk had an awkward stage
today they're the coolest cast in deep
space zoe saldana 'he's 18-month old
boys are just starting to understand how
special their mom is my husband started
very early on to show the boys um what I
do they're still having a hard time
understanding when they go mama mama you
know it's really funny that is so cute
I'm by the way Star Trek will be
everywhere this week in San Diego as
they celebrate the franchise's fiftieth
anniversary it is just one of the many
star-studded events that will take place
at comic-con and of course we will be
right there